okay folks
yes and i have to record this okay go
ahead hurry up
sorry it's raining we'll be quick
okay well
testing one two three testing
okay so um thank you for being here
now everyone knows the trump
administration came up with this
sort of ridiculous idea hhs
said that they were going to prioritize
santa claus performers for covet 19
vaccines
give me a break these are these are the
santas in the malls
first with covid we shouldn't have any
santas with kids sitting on their laps
or near them
but second doctors nurses
first responders they're the people who
should get the priority vaccines
not santa's sitting in the mall
and so the bottom line is this was so
laughed at that it's so laughed at that
the administration
withdrew this ridiculous proposal
but now there's 250 million dollars
sitting there to be used
to help fight covet there
it's just sitting there here's what we
propose
the administration reach into their
christmas sack
of the money they didn't spend on this
ridiculous santa idea
and do psas that everyone should wear a
face mask
we all know that face masks
oh sorry that everyone should wear a
face mask
we all know that face masks protect
people
they're one of the best ways to stop
covet from spreading
we now have a record number of
hospitalizations
covet is on the increase in all but a
few states
we must do more other countries that
have
have had the population use face masks
other countries that have had the
population use face masks
have seen covet reduced but this
administration
is ridiculous in its macho view that
face masks are the wrong thing to use
they don't listen to the scientists they
don't listen to dr
fauci they just go ahead and
put all of us in jeopardy donald trump
himself learned
that using face mask was a good idea
because he had the event
when they brought amy coney barrett to
the rose garden
no one had face masks and huge numbers
of people
got covert so the bottom line is very
simple
i love santa claus as much as the next
guy
but if even one of the single one of
these vulnerable
people would have had to wait for a
vaccine
because the sanders were getting it it
made no sense so i'm glad they stopped
that
but the bottom line is very simple and
that is
launch a national wear a mass campaign
using the 250 million dollars that's
sitting there
and do it a sap we're in our second wave
we may god forbid get a third wave
we've got to do everything we can and
the simple idea of wearing the masks the
scientists tell us
is one of the best ways to stop the
threat
spread
[Music]
[Music]
well look we've been waiting for the
administration and particularly
mcconnell's senate
to pass a corona relief bill we passed a
very strong bill in the house
it takes care of new york's and new york
city's governments it takes care of mass
transit it takes care of testing it
takes care of opening schools and many
other things
what's standing in the way is donald
trump and most of all
mcconnell's senate which doesn't want to
do any bill at all
we're ready to do one asap
well there's lots of things we want to
get done we want to deal
with covet first and we'll pass the
the big bill that the that's so good for
new york
that pass the house we will pass it in
the senate asap
and then we will move on helping working
families secure a better future better
education
dealing with climate dealing with the
restrictions on voting
dealing with so many different issues if
we get the majority we're going to work
very hard to have a big bold strong
agenda
that helps new york and helps average
americans
not just the people at the top anything
on the other
250 million
okay
the bottom line is that we first have to
get the majority because if we don't
nothing will happen
once it does our caucus will assemble
and
everything everything is on the table
thank you everybody and i'll take my wet
right
remarks